welcome to this video play endless
fighter and I keep forgetting the name
of this guy am sorry oh that's not even
there okay this is a bit bit reassuring
okay probably a king's indian yeah
classical king's indian nope Bishop g5
not a bad another bad line tried the
solid position online just trying to
develop here this was an old
recommendation in book by him I think it
was still gonna go back in the 90s when
I still played the King zinan on regular
basis okay yeah yeah I don't know queen
bee three he's see intending to take
problem but as a dangerous
ok can I can take that first this is not
a bad move and see how recaptures now I
can yeah can I just play b6 is this
possible yeah why not actually maybe you
can't marry can take on c5 I don't know
I probably not i was thinking taking c5
and B take sequin be seven but I've got
97 it's not not a problem Queen B 7 the
text rook and e7 hang so ok my ideas to
play just knight c6 and Quincy seven
something like that and then I should
have a good structure he's got the
double points and no clear on
compensation for that yeah yeah maybe is
he's intending to play Knights to d2 and
play eve form ok I probably cannot play
without that anyway
yeah you for their form mmm yeah yeah
okay at least for the moment before it's
not on but he can of course um prepare
that yep exactly like there hmm
maybe if I have something like that
my intention is to do follow up with g5
bishop g6 and then then move from then
move on the kingside cannons let's block
that can always protect b6 with Ruby a
tooth this is a common and current theme
from the NIMS l
hmm
yeah I really don't see the point
because I will get in at five I mean I
mean I can play that it's not it's not
like bad or anything but not sure that
this is really helping him
Queen Queen to h4 the idea and maybe f5
the right moment but okay first of all
I'd like to get the bird to d8 to
protect v6
no mm yep I'm very managed to blunder
this grade and yeah this was not exactly
necessary because he was at a dead end
already
oh right so how to drum up some play
here is this possible even Jake look
bassoon
I come on it's it's from the busted no
anyway
yeah I don't think this was necessary
really to to lose this position I'm not
sure maybe I'm terrible in bed shape on
long but I'm really not sure no this is
probably bad
yeah okay throw me I'm lost in this in
this end game okay
yeah i thought the end game is very very
good not that this is bad but the end
game looked like a fairly fairly simple
procedure
I've 9898 okay I'm absolutely not sure
that this is good for white not at all I
know it looks at first but he really was
at the dead end protecting my weakness
and if I don't blunder a five there's
absolutely nothing going on too I think
because on this I don't see how he
improves the computer actually gives it
as equal but of course after the the
pawn blunder I'm not instantly dead it
looks it looks quite awful I'm I'm aware
of that but it's not clear how he really
progresses I can try to get the rooks
back to the King side and I don't have
an attack here but how exactly does he
make any progress here he's attacking
the three times i'm defending her three
times you can't try on the King side I
mean of course why does the one to try
but this is the very resilient but ok i
blundered blundered the poem yeah thanks
for watching